oh this is are these big over here now
okay what are the tricks I mean it just
really literally just spins all right I
don't get I think this hi I'm Jamie Foxx
I'm Jon Hamm and we're here with that
vile a driver which is a Bible for lads
what we're going to be spending this
because reasons I'll spin
what should we just head i buy my nails
still that's just I'm too old to do that
when I was working crack
that's a terrible habit yeah you rather
have to say everything on you might
never speak again
then I be able to speak I would have a
hard time never speaking again you know
what's the best thing about British
people do a little more that British
accent repost it just sounds smarter
than we it goes that's my supposed to
see their attempted death is this
interview count my stop are you spin
yours terrible spin if you weren't in
showbiz what would you do I'd be a
lawyer
why's that I just liked it I would like
to argue who's your all-time funniest
co-star all-time touchdown Hannah that's
true would you would you rather be a
driver or would you rather be driven
I've read the dead or alive who would
you want in your heist crew dead or
alive anybody head or a lie alcohol
Muhammad Ali Ali Ali in danger I mean
gotta have somebody talk that [ __ ] and
then Jesus is never fair enough and he
would be pretty good at this you have to
get getaway over water you need
I hope
[Music]